welcome once again to our show and this
is Frank Avila usually we're discussing
political stuff for pop entertainment
stuff although we have done some
religious shows and I'm a lawyer so I'm
not an expert on these matters not a
theologian but I do I'm interested and I
do study these matters on my own and
today we have the Imam of the MCC
welcome again to our show we just did a
show earlier and we're gonna hopefully
do more shows with you and you can see
the show on wwe.com you click on video
you can put in my name
MC see the Imams name and you can see
these on right on your computer screen
anytime you want this will also be on
channels 19 or 21 and maybe on Channel
36 because this is a religious topic now
as a purpose I am a Catholic and I am a
practicing Catholic maybe not the best
one maybe even a bad one but I believe
in it I try to do it and I believe that
Jesus is true God and true man
I accept the Council of Nicaea that it
defines Jesus is true God and true man
and the Council of Chalcedon that
accepts Jesus is the hypostatic union
that he is perfectly in his wills true
God and true man and that Jesus is God
the Hebrew Messiah and the Messiah of
the world
however Muslims do not believe that and
rather than hear it from a polemicist
whether Christian or secular or Jewish
and there's a lot of misunderstanding
Islam and Christianity I want to hear it
from a Muslim themselves what they
believe and hear from that person so
there's not a misunderstanding because
ignorance is not a good thing and I and
I believe you are a mainline Sunni as
Muslim because there are different as he
would call deviations or sects in Islam
astray each one of them believes they're
true but the main sect or main part
would certainly is Lama cut the sunnis
right and they are the majority of Islam
and so the topic today because we're
already on topics on the definition of
God in Islam which I guess we'll have to
touch on again if Jesus is God
Christiane's than he and I really we
already know that he's not God to
Muslims who is Jesus in Islam Jesus in
Islam is a Messenger of God one of the
best messengers of God and God had
revealed to him to call the children of
Israel to worship the creator of the
heavens and the earth and he mentioned
also about the coming of prophet
muhammed being to find a messenger so
are the messengers whether it's from
Adam and Noah and Abraham and Moses and
Jesus and Prophet Muhammad and all that
is in between there are brothers they
came with the same message and that is
voice of the creator of the heavens and
the earth so we considered Jesus as a
messenger of Islam Islam means it's not
just is LEM but it means the messenger
of submitting ourselves to the creator
of the heavens in here okay now before
we start because somebody may see this
show and not have seen the other show
tell us briefly your background and I'm
assuming in Egypt also that I don't know
how long you live there but you may have
interacted with Christians because you
do have Orthodox Christians you have
Maronites from Lebanon and maybe
emigrated for business Melkite as well
as the main of original Christians to
Coptic Christians which have Nicaea but
did not accept Chalcedon although
they've and they were separated from
Egypt in Ethiopia and they their leader
is in Alexandria Egypt but first tell us
what your background oh you're in
physics but tell us all about that your
study of religion and then your
interaction with Christians I studied in
Egypt in the school of Arabic and
Islamic studies and I have a chemistry
Bachelor from Egypt and I have a physics
better from here from Southern Illinois
University and an MBA from the same
University and I memorized the Quran and
I studied the tradition way methods of
religion from sitting with the scholars
and having certificates from them and
things of that nature
now you literally sit with the scholars
and have discussions I've seen pictures
the ancient kind of drawings as well as
even where the the somebody sits down on
like fellow type of things and you talk
back and forth one of them is isn't
analogous recent in kiosks
okay yes yes and so you'd warned by
analogy right actually there's a unique
thing in among the Muslims when it comes
to learning their religion there is
something called the chain of narrations
like for example if I study something
with one of the scholars here at the end
he would give me the certificate but the
unique thing is that it has the name of
the one that he took it from and then
the one that he took it from so I have
it all the way that traces back to
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him so
this is called a J's I think the same
thing for the Quran would be in English
maybe lineage lineage with exactly every
name all the way to the Prophet Muhammad
because it's one from one generation
give it to the next and are in Cairo
what if I might have I know correctly
that was one of the first universities
in the world the idea of the sheet now
that we have in the West to seat but
what is the name of doesn't oh yes
allows huh
so these are ancient learning
institutions and even in the pre-islamic
world
Egypt had a great Christian presence and
then even before that we know about the
ancient Egyptian centers of learning and
the ancient Egyptian which is I think
dead completely if I'm not mistaken
nobody yeah actually there's something
here from America that they still have
these types of believes and they go
there and Egypt and they had certain
days where they closed the temples in
them and they they do some extra voice
upon Egypt no okay but of the ancient
Pharaoh's Tutankhamun the different
things that we've studied the Ramses the
the supposing one was monotheistic even
I believe right they claimed it yes
right and the Terr pyramids and the
Sphinx and all this and then Egypt has a
close connection to Christianity because
it's believed that when the Roman Roman
well would be the well the Romans but
the Jewish emperor of the Romans Herod I
believe was slaughtering the children
because he didn't want a new king as he
thought Jesus was a material King that
he was killing the children that that
the angel came to Joseph said go to
Egypt and then Joseph Mary and Jesus
went to Egypt although that's much known
about their life there that's not
discussed so there's a connection here
did you deal with Christians in Egypt oh
yes of course we have
neighbors we have you know students in
the school everywhere in the streets
it's it's a daily interaction of course
okay and there's many different types of
questions but again mostly the biggest
population would be the Coptic Christian
right and there's Catholics and others
yeah six and there's some prominent ones
I can't think his name but there's a
billionaire construction magnate who is
a Coptic Christian right I can't think
of his name but he built a lot in Iraq
and he's a very big construction and
then Boutros boutros-ghali of the UN is
Coptic and now I don't want to discuss
it too long as we should do another show
but I have heard from some Coptic French
you said this to believe you but that
one of the issues of who Jesus is in LOM
some Christians say that they are
treated poorly in Islamic countries and
I don't want that to be the whole topic
but that some cops were shot by Islamic
Brotherhood that some of them have a
difficulty rising to the top although
I've also heard from Faisal maha muda
muda who's a friend of mine and also
some enough top that the is the Egyptian
government is also very tough on the
Islamic Brotherhood they put people in
jail persecuted them I've heard even
tortured them and many of them have to
emigrate because of the the way the
government is under Hosni Mubarak so
maybe this briefly discuss that mm-hm
well for any claim of course we do not
take things but just claims so for
people to find out because they might
not take my word for it because maybe
they don't know me or whatever so it's
important for people to find out
themselves and to good for example to
Egypt and see and if there is a you know
to allegations or not but things are
controlled over needed so for example in
the mosques there we don't have the same
freedom as people would have the freedom
in the churches so which is something
there is very strange but you have more
freedom and master here in the United
States in Egypt yes at least to say what
you wanted right right but again this is
doesn't not necessarily something bad in
Egypt because you don't also want things
to be spread in an evil way or in a
corruption way side these are differents
and what fits in one society is
different than what fits in another
society so again
we have neighbors and you know things in
the mainstream in Egypt you won't find
things that would be that disturbing and
actually it's it's getting more and more
- as if somebody is trying to to ignite
something there which is very sad
actually what people live together for
thousands of years okay well let's get
back to the original topic and we can go
back into our bees there's a priest
he's a Coptic priests never met him
don't know him and I don't speak Arabic
nor Coptic or gi's or any other language
a little bit of Arabic Marc about if I
like stuff like that but is that he is
on TV and supposedly he converts Muslims
to Coptic I think he's well known you
may even be familiar with them I can't
think of his name but supposedly he's
not in communion with Baba Shenouda the
Pope or the patriarch of the of the cops
but I preface with that is that you've
dealt with Christians you've studied I'm
assuming Christianity and you have a
Western background in the sense you have
two bachelor's degree in scientific
fields from a public secular University
as well as an MBA I think from the same
University you said so you've been any
public American secular scientific
materialists kind of Cartesian worldview
as well as a traditional Islamic world
view right and with all that background
I'm sure you know something then about
Christianity as well as a practical way
of dealing Christians you're Catholic or
Orthodox or Coptic neighbors Frank
so who then is Jesus in Islam you were
starting that well because I believe in
Christians believe traditional
Christians not all Christians because
there's Aryan Christians there's
Christian deviations that Jesus is God
that he is the Messiah and some believe
that like you believe about the Prophet
Muhammad that after Jesus there was no
revelation so to who to Muslims who is
Jesus to Muslims Jesus is a human being
created from flesh not God
not God but he is one of the special
human beings why was he born of a virgin
right he was born of a virgin which is
Mary and actually the story of Jesus is
mentioned in the Quran in a very
detailed manner
of how Mary gave birth to Jesus from no
father whatsoever and this is how to
perfect the whole way of God created he
created Adam from no father or mother he
created Eve from Adam and he created
Jesus from no father so this is the
miracle of God
so in us in Islam while Adam is more
deserving to be God than if he didn't
have a father or a mother but again he
is one Jesus is one of the great
messengers of God and that as mentioned
no quran we exalt his mention and we
believed that he would return again at
the end of the world and he would
descend because he's not dead yet he was
resurrected as its mentioned Nicole and
he was not crucified he would be turned
back and he would rule people with
justice and he would rule with them or
rule them with the Sharia and the
rulings of Islam came by Prophet
Muhammad you say yeah
that is the law in Islam okay all right
this briefly because there it's a very
interesting topic there's more than one
Sharia law however because I studied a
little bit in college with Egyptian
Sharif passione he gave the keynote
speed that Kara the console Islam for
relations when I studied with him
College he said there's numerous
shuddery laws I don't was twelve or two
I don't know the number so there's not
one Sharia law well there is in Islam
there are things that has no differences
of opinions whatsoever methods of belief
basic methods in the religion basic
methods of the rulings of Sharia and
there are other things what has
differences of opinions based on
explanation of the texts and everything
but these issues would not bring harm to
the rulings of the people and this is a
way for people to exert more and to
struggle more and to seek rewards more
and that in but it's only in branches of
things not in the basic or the core
principles of Sharia and the basic even
rulings in Sharia
so the the point is that he would be
coming back right for the the justice of
the human beings but again would not
bring in another new religion because
again and this is something if it's a
claim it's something for the people to
figure out themselves a Prophet Mohammed
came with a comprehensive message that
it speaks for itself that
perfect an audit sense because this is
what we believe right and it does
there's no need for another messenger to
come but when it comes to the message of
Jesus it came more into the spirituality
that the children of Israel at the time
they needed it but then the Prophet
Muhammad he came with the combination of
what Moses came with and Jesus came with
and that is you have the rights to take
your rights but at the same time you are
ordered to have the spirituality and to
forgive and so on okay what now let me
it's two questions if Jesus came
different animal you said was the first
we understand that he was uncreated but
if Jesus was not born of a man then
wouldn't that be an indication that
indeed he was a God he's the only person
was Adam but he was the first you can
understand because so the secularist
would say maybe the atheists are
agnostic or even a religious person was
secular say well how can a man be born
without a father without the sexual
sexual act without procreation without
semen entering you know to the womb and
creating human life right this is a
great miracle right or something that's
impossible and not true and mythology or
number two if this is true to me this
would be an indication that Jesus is or
at least could be God that he was born
of a virgin well if we save adam for
exemple he did not have a feather our
mother when it comes to jesus to say
that his god would either proof of that
plus you know he was in the womb of mary
wilma the mayor of a mother that means
with all the blood and everything like
that and how can the almighty powerful
be in such a place right and again the
the matter is not about whether it's
true or not the matter is what is the
proof of that and in islam there is no
proof of that and as we know the jews
day they deny that and jesus himself did
not say that according to the revelation
from god and that's why it bringing be
people back to the true religion of
Jesus that he came with and that is what
the first words that came out of the
mouth of Jesus when he was born when the
children of Israel said to Mary how can
you do that out of without marriage and
things like that he said in Abood Allah
that I am a slave of Allah so this is
the first words that he said that he is
a creation of the creator of the heavens
in here now to understand Islamic
relationship with Jesus to me is
necessary also to analyze his
relationship with his
they're merry or is an Arabic money I'm
am I saying it right now okay and and
some Protestants are violating their own
Bible because he said well we believe in
the Bible but in the Gospel of Luke it
says the angel Gabriel comes to Mary and
says hail Mary full of grace
bless her at the home a woman and your
name shall be blessed for all
generations so if the name is blessed
for all generations but then Protestant
scholars have the generator the name of
Mary and they're not blessing her name
they don't honor her name but when I was
in Turkey and Ephesus I did see Muslims
come to the shrine of Mary to venerate
in some way and in the quran there are
quotations honoring Mary they believe
she's a virgin and holder and very high
esteem so it seems that Muslims actually
hold Mary and higher esteem than some
Protestant Christians it's definitely
actually there's a chapter in the Quran
chapter Surat Maryam this is the chapter
of Mary the only chapter that has the
name of a woman is the name of Mary if
the prophets allah and prophet muhammad
made up this religion he would have
named it after one of his wife's hadisha
but instead he said that the best woman
ever created is Mary and the one that I
was perfect so we in Islam we put Mary
please be upon hunt beasts be upon her
in a very high level and she's the best
of the women of course and again she was
dead because Allah chose her to have
Jesus and to be devoted and worshipping
God alone and not to depend on her heart
would to anyone but the creator of the
heavens in here okay because it is
interesting that many Muslims have a
very high honor for Mary right and
that's very similar obviously to
Orthodox Christians - or Coptic
Christians as well as Catholics of
course but in understanding then Mary
and the relationship to Jesus you don't
you if you don't believe Jesus is gone
do you believe he is the Jewish Messiah
that he is the most high acti Messiah to
the Jewish people correct that he was a
messenger human being Allah God sent him
to the guidance of the children of
Israel when they diverted away from the
message of Moses peace be upon him so
the spirituality was missing there and
he sent him for that message and he was
tested so much right but he was not
crucified instead he was lifted to the
heavens and he's still alive and he
would
back to live on the first face of Earth
so then we would have the real death
after that
okay now Christians believe that Jesus
pre-existed so in the Gospel of John it
says in the beginning was the word and
the Word was God and the Word was with
God but in Islam it seems that the word
is the qur´an is that correct right and
that some people in Islam believe that
the Koran pre-existed creation hmm is
that true
actually no the Quran is the exact words
of God okay
God spoke the Quran it's not a creation
that pre-existed God spoke the Quran and
it was given to Gabriel and then he
spoke the Quran well and in his mind did
he have the crown in his mind before
creation this is something that we we do
not believe in that we believe that he
spoke the Quran of course God he's the
one that knows what's in the past in the
future but he spoke it as an actual
thing that he spoke but do some Muslims
believe that the Quran pre-existed yes
and it's actually we consider that and
Sony believe that it's a deviation
because it's mention the Quran that it's
the words of God okay now who is it the
Shia then who believe that it's the
pre-existence or a certain Sunni sex
certain sexist okay now because it seems
to me that there's a similarity if you
call the Quran the word and Jesus is
known as the word in Greek logos that
that the Koran and Jesus then become
similar type of concepts actually in the
plan it says that Jesus is the word of
God it means that he was created by the
word couldn't which means be and he was
so God ordered for him to be created and
he was created so this is the meaning of
the word so since we everybody is a
creation of God and Jesus also a
creation of God but a special way in a
special way he was created by the Word
of God by the Word of God saying for it
to be and it happened rather than a
physical procreative manner right that's
normal and biological okay now so you
don't believe Jesus is God but you do
believe he's the Hebrew Messiah right
but now but you don't believe that he is
a savior in that and and how the
Christians believe no but he's a savior
if people follow his teacher his deed
Shinx to worship the creator of the
heavens and the earth then this is how
he's a savior to the people at his time
and for those who would follow him they
would follow the message also of prophet
muhammad since he exalted with Jesus
head and all the messengers before and
came with the same message of Jesus so
the same message is for a person to
adopt what prophet muhammad came which
is the same as a Jew Jesus so now most
Christians believe that Jesus died on
the cross that this is preordained that
he chawl so chose to do it that he was
nailed to the cross suffered and died
for our sins and this was the plan after
Adam had and Eve had sinned that and the
sin-stained our soul in some way and so
it was unnecessary for redemption so God
became in as the Incarnation didn't
carnation a lot of sacramental world
view and that Jesus on the cross was a
substitute of vicarious atonement so the
Muslims then believed in a sake by
Carius atonement because even if I'm not
mistaken some Muslims during the
celebration of when Abraham made a
sacrifice still make sacrifice I know if
it's a symbol but in ancient Jews made
the sacrifice at the temple most
religions make sacrifice when I was in
Mexico you know I saw that and this was
this is unfortunate but some did human
sacrifice to the different gods as an
intone Minh for that the blood healed
the land but that's even in Old
Testament blood hill the land so is
their sacrifice in Islam number one and
number two was there a sacrifice that
Jesus made that one should believe in
that covers the sins of man the
sacrifice in Islam is a sacrifice that
each individual has to go through with
his own atonement and that is to
sacrifice once time and one's wealth and
things like that even if he has to
sacrifice his life for the Word of God
and for protecting his own religion to
be patient and fulfilling it but as far
as the the concept of sacrificing
someone for the Tumen of everybody know
in Islam it says there's a verse in the
Quran well at a zero a zero two mu zero
ha that means no soul shall bear the
burden of another soul someone's
grandfather committed a crime I'm not
responsible for that if I'm an offspring
so this cancer is very clear in this
lamb so the sin of Adam peace be upon
him it's mentioned the Quran that God
forgave him when he see when he sought
forgiveness from
and then dementedly over but is there
original sin then the original sin was
already forgiven as it's mentioned but
then we're not perfect human beings at
the time of Eden so were you and I
aren't walking without death we have
illness at the time of Adam in the
garden there was no illness it was
perfection right but because of the sin
of Adam we came onto the face of earth
and then Adam repented and it was
forgiven and it was accepted and that's
why every human being is born sinless
honestly newly born baby he's not born
in the sin he's born sinless and then
when he reached the age of puberty then
he accumulated the mistakes but then the
the gates of repentance is open but just
asking God for it so if the baby is
sinless then how do you account then for
illness and death that would not be
present in a perfect knowledge of God or
in Eden all these physical illnesses and
death is basically something that God
decreed because this life is not the
life it's only a passage to the
Hereafter
so whether a person lives for ten years
or hundred years it doesn't really
matter what matters is how he lived
these years because compared to
everlasting to infinity it's nothing so
these things has to be there for the
test of the human being for certain
qualities of good human beings to show
like patience and being content and so
on
so if Jesus did not die in the cross
what happened in the Quran it says that
someone else was put on him the
resemblance of Jesus and instead Jesus
was lifted and this is actually the more
honorable version of how Jesus was dealt
with as the belief of us as Muslims that
he was lifted and this is mentioned the
Quran say again it's not some opinions
that people made up because it's
something that is unseen to us he was
lifted to the heavens and God said that
he will come back at the end of the
world for the justice of the people and
to make the matter clear to the people
because all the confusion you're saying
that Jesus was at what point was he
taking them to heaven when he was on the
cross you know before he was put on the
cross before was put on the cross and
then somebody else was in this place
that looked like Jesus but that seems
more illogical or ridiculous than Jesus
dying on the cross
well it might to some that do not
believe of course in Revelations but
among the Christians also there's so
much different beliefs when it comes to
Jesus and
that's why there was needed for another
revelation to come there it's miraculous
in its wordings that would give the
right version of the story right and
since its method that people differed
among themselves so how can we believe
which is right and which is wrong first
the Quran if we prove that it's the Word
of God then we believe in what's ever in
it so the the homework should be done
earlier whether the Quran is the word of
God or not and it's miraculous in itself
that which God challenged the human
beings to bring something the like of it
well but even if Christians believe
disagreed on different ideas which is
certainly true especially in the early
Christian stages different heresies you
had Gnostics you had different Aryans
historians etc is that all of them
believe that Jesus died on the cross
nobody ever denied in Christianity that
Jesus died on the cross he made tonight
he was God
they might deny he was just teaching but
they all agreed he was denied I'm died
on the cross the cross is the central
symbol in Christianity right but the the
issue with dying on the cross first what
is the real or the materialistic
evidence is that this has happened and
the other thing is why would God dies on
the cross you know what is the the basic
things behind it when he is simply would
forgive whoever he wants to forgive and
they will be forgiven and how can people
would spit and cause pain to the Son of
God right this is something that if we
if we love Jesus so much and he is
having the help of God he would not be
in such a state and that's why we freed
him from such humiliation but instead he
was resurrected and someone else was
crucified and not him okay
now let's talk a little bit about esta
Tala geez that the right word they get
that right the theology of the last
things because you stated that Jesus
will come again so you believe in a
second coming as Christians believe in a
second coming
so as Jesus then the judge of the living
and the dead at the second coming
what do you mean by the judge of the
living and it did well in the Apostles
Creed and the Nicene Creed they say that
we believe in the second coming that
jesus will be the judge of the living
and the dead the time of the judge
judgment Jesus will be present it will
be on the face of Earth
not on the day of judgment and he would
judge those who are life and those who
would not believe in him they would die
by without no fighting right and he
would fight the Antichrist and
Antichrist will die and after that
justice will be all over the earth and
there was so much blessings in it right
and actually he would make the
pilgrimage to Mecca as it's mentioned by
the sayings of the Prophet Muhammad and
to mention the Quran that he will come
back and he will spread peace and
harmony among the people in the face of
earth but then after that he will die a
natural death and as a creation of God
and then people will generation after
generation they will start you know the
decline of the faith will happen and
then a wind will be sent that would take
the souls of the believers so that only
disbelievers will be on the face of
earth and on these people the day of
judgment will occur so he's only a human
being that will come as a as a follower
of Prophet Muhammad meaning dealing with
people with justice on the face of earth
but not a judge and on to the dead you
know we only got a minute left what I
want to do in last minute is give your
contact information or if anybody wants
to contact you maybe if they want to
watch the Deen show learn more and if
there's other Christians who want to ask
you questions about Jesus and if you
have a last minute message about who
Jesus is in Islam right well it's very
important for people at least to try to
study the religion of Islam since
everybody heard about it so it's fair
enough because we know about
Christianity is something by default as
a Muslim that we have to believe in
Jesus so it's fair enough for people to
study and to read the Quran and if we
say that it's miraculous wordings of God
that the challenge is that people would
not be able to even bring the like of
one chapter of it so for people to study
that and we're there to answer questions
and I mean MCC in Chicago in Elston and
you can log in to the website of the of
the of the mosque and you can ask
questions or the Deen show and it's such
a wonderful thing to interact with
others and again the message is since
God is one so it's message is one and
that's probably we need to worship alone
man thank you very much for being on our
show that's about all the time we have
left to our viewing audience I hope you
found this interesting I hope you
learned something
contact us for the show thank you for
watching goodbye and God bless you